i'm going to construct a sequence where
i start with some number let's say i
start with the number a and then each
successive term of the sequence i'm
going to multiply the pre to get each
successive term of the sequence i'm
going to multiply the previous term by
some fixed non-zero number and i'm going
to call that r so the next term is going
to be a
is going to be a times r
and then the term after that i'm going
to apply i'm going to multiply this
thing times r so it's going to be a
if you if you multiply ar times r that's
going to be a r
a r squared and then if you were to
multiply this
term times r you would get a
times
r
to the third power and you could keep
going on and on and on and on and this
type of sequence or this type of
progression is called a geometric
geometric
sequence or progression
geometric sequence you start with some
first value let me circle that in a
different color since i already used the
green so you start with some first value
and then each success to get each
successive term you multiply by this
fixed number and in this case this fixed
number is r
and so we call r our common ratio
our common
ratio why is it called a common ratio
we'll take any two successive terms take
this term and this term and divide this
term by this term right over here a r to
the third divided by a r squared so if
you find the ratio between these two
things a let me rewrite this same colors
so if you took a r to the third power
and we're divided by the term before it
so if you were divided by
a
r squared what are you going to be left
with
well a divided by a is 1 r to the third
divided by r squared is just going to be
r and this is true if you divide any
term by the term before if you find the
ratio between any term and the term
before it is going to be r and so that's
why it's called a common ratio and so
let's look something look at some
examples of geometric sequences so if i
start with the number
if i start with the number 5 so my a is
5 and then each time i'm going to
multiply i'm going to multiply by i
don't know let's say i multiply by 1 7
so then the next term is going to be 5
over 7
5 over 7. what's the next term going to
be well i'm going to multiply this thing
times 1 7 so that's going to be 5 7
times 1 7 is 5 49. so it's going to be 5
over
5 over 7 squared or 49 if i were to
multiply this times 1 7 what am i going
to get and i'll just change the notation
i'll just get 5 times i don't actually
know in my head what 7 to the third
power is i guess i could calculate it
280
plus 63.
let's see so that would be c7 times 40
is 280 7 times 9 is 63
so you're going to get to 343
i believe let me see did i do that right
7 times 280 plus 63 is 343 and you can
just keep going
so this right over here is an example of
a geometric
of a geometric sequence started with
some first value and each successive
value i multiplied by 1 7. 1 7 is the
common ratio here let me give you
another one
let's say i have this
so let's say i have 3
and then let's say i have
6
and let's say i have
12
let's then i have
24
then i have 48. is this a geometric
series and if it is what is the common
ratio here
well you could figure out the common
ratio by just taking any two successive
terms and dividing well first you could
you could
try it with two terms so 12 divided by
six is two so we have to multiply by two
to go from 12 to 24 you multiplied by 2
to go from 24 to 48 you have to multiply
by 2. to go from 3 to 6 we have to
multiply by 2. so you had a fixed common
ratio for if any of these terms we
multiplied by 2 and then say multiplied
by 3
and and so we didn't multiply by the
same thing then it wouldn't be a
geometric sequence anymore
so this clearly is a geometric sequence
i forgot to mention that